so there's a new story out there that
solves a little bit of a mystery uh in
that ever since the 1960s where people
first flew uh space probes around the
far side of the moon so the side of the
moon that we don't actually get to see
from the earth
and started taking pictures they found
that actually rather bizarrely the far
side of the moon looks very different
from the near side of the moon in that
there are many more mountain ranges on
the far side of them the near side of
the moon has some craters but mostly
it's these sort of big flat plains these
things called seas or mares so it's
always been a bit of a mystery it's how
you can form an astronomical body like
the moon with one side of it so
different from the other side of it
so there's now an explanation as to
probably how this came about which is
it there's a reasonably well accepted
theory as to how the moon formed which
is sometimes early in the formation of
the solar system there was no moon but
some
other body in the early solar system
came along and smacked into the earth
sort of threw a whole load of material
up into space and that material
coalesced to form the moon
and so this new idea is that maybe it
didn't originally coalesce to form one
body maybe it initially coalesced to
form two bodies one rather larger than
the other and in fact you can do that
and the two objects will happily share
the same orbit for some considerable
time but eventually they'll probably
bump into each other and this is what
and and bumping into it each other is
probably the right way of thinking about
it in the sense that they they did merge
with one another but it wasn't a huge
massive collision because if you have a
huge massive collision either you'll
smash them to pieces or your very least
you'll end up forming a huge impact
crater or something like that so
probably the two sort of merged together
relatively gently
and when they merged together the place
the side of the moon where all this
extra material got added would form a
whole load of mountains it's basically
mostly the material that you've added on
but also that's kind of the impact on
the on the surface will kind of create
folds and new new mountains and so on
there will be some molten rock form
because it's still reasonably hot when
all this happens it's a reasonably
energetic collision that molten rock
will then flow around to the other side
of the moon and produce the very smooth
uh kind of lava flows that we see on the
other side of the moon so this is rather
neat model for actually explaining how
you can end up with a moon that looks so
different on the two sides
okay i'm gonna
work with the 16 here and see what i can
do
is this
based on any evidence or is this just a
hypothesis that makes a lot of sense
it's
so
the the guys who've done this have done
a series of calculations to figure out
that you can actually have these kind of
three body systems that they will
coexist happily so the earth and these
two moons will correlate happily for a
long time and that actually when they do
merge together you can arrange things
without being too kind of contrived
about the whole thing they will actually
tend to merge in this fairly gentle
fashion they won't smack into each other
at a high speed i suspect it will
probably be a kind of a plausible theory
for the foreseeable future in that you
might for example one way of trying to
figure out whether two things whether a
particular object is formed from two
separate things is to look at the
chemical composition and see if it
varies from place to place but here of
course both the moons formed in the same
original impact and so actually they
were probably made up of more or less
the same material and so you're probably
not really going to be able to tell
which is one moon and which is the other
when you even if you could collect large
samples from the moon
but the boulder must be
about a meter long with
two to three inch layers
i think yeah plausible probable yeah i'd
be happy with probable it's you know if
it it so the essence of science is to
try and come up with the simplest
explanation that explains as many things
as possible it's this thing called
occam's razor that says the simplest
explanation is the best and the nice
thing is that this single uh idea
actually explains quite a lot of the
properties of the moon so as such it's
kind of a good theory but it is still a
theory there's some stuff in there
when astronomers were trying to figure
out where the moon came from they
eventually came up with this collision
theory
now they're trying to figure out why the
moon has these two different aspects to
it and again they've come up with a
collision theory it just seems like
every time there's something they can't
figure out they say oh it must have been
a big collision it's always fun smashing
things into all these yellows the same
with galaxies right the way we like to
make bigger galaxies is by smashing
smaller galaxies together it's always
fun to crash things into each
about the other
40 to 50 percent level down
yeah i see what you mean yeah see that
all the way across